Hébreux 6, verset 20, deuxième partie du verset 20.
« Ayant été fait souverain sacrificateur pour toujours, selon l'ordre de Melchisedec. »
On s'approche progressivement, lentement mais progressivement, du cœur de l'Épitre.
Le cœur de l'Épitre, c'est le chapitre 7, qu'on va détailler les semaines qui vont arriver.
Et le cœur de l'Épitre aux Hébreux a pour thème le sacerdoce de Christ, c'est-à-dire Christ en tant que souverain sacrificateur.
Christ est le souverain sacrificateur de l'humanité rachetée.
Il est notre médiateur entre Dieu et nous, son peuple.
Mais avant de revenir dans ce thème que l'auteur avait déjà abordé au chapitre 4,
l'auteur avait fait une grande parenthèse de deux chapitres.
Une parenthèse au chapitre 5 et une parenthèse au chapitre 6.
Et aujourd'hui, on conclut cette parenthèse.
Mais cette parenthèse et cette longue parenthèse n'avaient qu'un seul but.
Si on devait résumer cette parenthèse en une phrase,
eh bien que les auditeurs puissent revenir au thème du sacerdoce avec plus de concentration,
avec plus de zèle, avec un cœur prêt à recevoir les enseignements de la doctrine.
Il a quitté des personnes au chapitre 4 qui n'étaient pas prêts à recevoir de toute évidence l'enseignement sur le sacerdoce.
Ils étaient paresseux, ils se contentaient de la petite doctrine,
ils se contentaient simplement du lait,
et l'auteur a dû s'arrêter,
prendre deux chapitres pour les avertir,
pour les reprendre,
pour les avertir au risque d'être exposés à de si grandes doctrines
et de rester impassibles, apathiques.
Et ensuite, maintenant,
à la fin de cette grande parenthèse,
eh bien l'auteur enfin revient,
estimant avoir fait le nécessaire
pour réveiller la concentration,
le zèle des auditeurs.
Et nous sommes donc dans cette transition
vers ce chapitre 7.
Et il semble que les auditeurs,
et c'est là où on les a retrouvés au chapitre 4,
les auditeurs commençaient à manifester
un attachement progressif
ou un réattachement progressif
envers l'ancienne sacrificature.
Ils revenaient à la religion progressive
corrompue de leur père,
juif,
eux qui avaient été chassés des synagogues
et qui avaient pourtant professé la foi chrétienne,
eh bien progressivement,
re-regardaient en arrière
à cette ancienne sacrificature.
Et il semble que pour eux,
eh bien l'articulation du panorama biblique,
l'articulation entre l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
était à peu près floue.
C'était quelque chose
qui n'était pas tout à fait clair pour eux.
D'où cet attrait pour l'ancienne sacrificature.
Il semble que pour eux,
ce que Christ est vraiment venu accomplir
n'était pas tout à fait clair devant leurs yeux.
Ils ont été enseignés en Christ.
Ils ont même professé leur foi en Christ.
Mais quelle était la plénitude du ministère de Christ ?
Pour eux, ce n'était pas tout à fait clair.
C'étant limité simplement
au abaissé de la foi
et ne s'étant pas approfondi dans la doctrine.
Et alors que nous allons commencer
dans les semaines à venir
à aborder le sacerdoce de Christ,
vous pouvez me demander
mais c'est quoi le rapport avec nous ?
On n'est pas juif.
Enfin, je ne crois pas qu'il y ait des juifs parmi nous.
Mais on n'est pas juif.
On n'est pas du premier siècle.
On ne sort pas des synagogues.
Notre tentation,
ce n'est pas d'aller dans le temple de Jérusalem
et de sacrifier à nouveau.
Quel est le rapport avec nous
de nous parler à nouveau
de la supériorité du sacerdoce de Christ
et de nous montrer le panorama biblique ?
Eh bien, la tentation en essence
que rencontrait le peuple juif
est la même tentation
qu'aujourd'hui les Églises rencontrent.
Et les mêmes symptômes
qui manifestaient ce retour en arrière
de la part du peuple juif
sont en réalité des symptômes
que nous avons toujours vus
dans l'histoire de l'Église.
Le rapport flou entre l'Ancien
et le Nouveau Testament.
le manque de compréhension
de comment toutes ces alliances
qui ont été présentées
dans l'Ancien Testament
étaient au service
de la Nouvelle Alliance.
Tout cela,
ce sont des choses
que l'Église même contemporaine
rencontre encore aujourd'hui.
Et ce flou,
j'allais dire ce flou artistique,
mais ce flou de compréhension,
eh bien,
se manifeste de plusieurs façons
dans l'Église aujourd'hui.
Certains vont être attirés
par,
comme les Juifs dans les Hébreux,
certains vont être attirés
par la religion ancienne.
Il y a un côté rassurant
à voir la rigueur liturgique,
à avoir une suite,
une succession de rites,
ça rassure celui qui est instable.
Et on l'a vu notamment
dans la saison du Covid en France,
comment de nombreux jeunes
enquêtent,
complètement enquêtent
de sens,
de stabilité,
eh bien,
vont se retourner progressivement
vers des formes
plus traditionnelles de religion.
Parce qu'il y a un côté rassurant
de se confier
dans une religion historique
simplement parce qu'elle est historique.
Synonyme pour eux
de stabilité.
Et les Hébreux
ont eu cette tentation également
de retrouver dans la religion
de leur père
une certaine stabilité
et de faire de la stabilité,
de la rigueur,
de la piété,
eh bien,
une forme de piété
en elle-même.
Une autre manifestation
de ce flou
entre l'Ancien
et le Nouveau Testament,
c'est peut-être au contraire
cet attrait
que certains juifs
avaient pour le mystérieux
et le mystique
qu'il y avait
dans l'Ancienne Alliance.
Il y avait dans cette
Ancienne Alliance
des choses
qui n'étaient pas
tout à fait claires,
des choses qui étaient
assez floues
dans le rapport
et dans l'approche
de l'adorateur
envers Dieu.
et peut-être que certains
des juifs
ont considéré,
comme certains contemporains
et comme certaines églises
pentecôtistes
et charismatiques,
ont considéré
qu'on ne pouvait approcher
le divin
que par des pratiques
qui dépassent
notre entendement.
Alors cet attrait
vers les choses
mystérieuses et mystiques,
ce manque de compréhension
que ce qui avait été décrit
peut-être de façon
assez sombre
avait pour vocation
d'être clarifié
dans la révélation progressive,
eh bien ce manque
de compréhension
de l'Ancienne
et de la Nouvelle Alliance
peut se manifester
par un attrait
du symbolique,
du mystérieux,
du rite mystique.
Et enfin,
je pense que là
vous êtes plus familier
par cette tentation
et cette manifestation
de ce même problème.
Le flou
entre l'Ancienne
et la Nouvelle Alliance
peut aussi se manifester
tout simplement
par des mauvaises interprétations
de l'Ancien Testament.
Ou on va prendre
des personnages
de l'Ancien Testament
et en faire
des modèles
de piété,
de morale
pour notre propre vie
déconnectés
de Jésus-Christ.
Ou David
va devenir
un héros
pour nous
et savoir
comment se comporter
face à l'ennemi,
déconnectés
de Christ.
Ou on va prendre
d'autres personnages
de la Bible
et finalement
l'Ancien Testament
ne sera qu'une collection
de modèles
à suivre
ou à ne pas suivre
mais complètement
dénués
de leurs valeurs
typologiques
en Jésus-Christ.
Voilà
une des manifestations
de l'absence
de compréhension,
comment l'Ancienne
et la Nouvelle Alliance
s'articulent
et comment
Jésus-Christ
est le plein
accomplissement
de l'Ancien Testament.
Le plein
accomplissement
de l'Ancienne Alliance.
Pour eux,
pour les Hébreux,
comme
on l'a dit
dans une prière
ce matin,
Jésus-Christ
était bien
le prophète
des Hébreux,
des auditeurs
de cet Épitre.
Jésus-Christ
était bien
même leur sauveur.
Ils ont fait
profession de foi
à Jésus-Christ.
C'était un grand prophète,
un homme de Dieu,
peut-être même
pour certains
le Fils de Dieu.
Mais
il semble que
le lien
entre tout
ce qui précédait
Christ
et l'avènement
de Jésus-Christ
par son ministère
pour eux
n'était pas
tout à fait clair encore.
Et ils ont peut-être
vu Jésus
comme la continuité
de grands hommes
qui ont été envoyés
de la part de Dieu.
Et dans ce cas-là,
ce n'est pas étonnant
qu'ils regardent en arrière,
qu'ils voient Jésus-Christ
comme étant un grand homme,
mais qu'ils regardent
aussi en arrière
et commencent
à estimer
et à porter
une attention particulière
sur d'autres hommes
soit qui ont précédé Christ,
soit qui ont vécu
aux côtés de Christ,
soit qui ont suivi Christ.
Et on le voit encore
dans un bon nombre
de dénominations
qui s'appellent chrétiennes.
Des personnes
qui remettent leur sort
non pas en Jésus-Christ seul,
mais en des personnes
qui ont côtoyé Christ,
la mère de Christ,
ou en des saints
qui ont côtoyé Christ,
ou des saints
qui ont suivi Christ.
flou total
entre l'ancienne
et la nouvelle alliance.
Flou total
dans la compréhension
de ce que Jésus
a fait dans cette histoire.
Flou total
entre le lien
de toutes ces alliances
et le plein accomplissement
en Jésus-Christ.
Manque de compréhension
que Christ n'est pas simplement
le centre de l'histoire,
comme si c'était un personnage
avant qui il y avait quelque chose
et après qui il y aurait
quelque chose.
Christ est l'accomplissement
de l'histoire.
Christ est le fondement
de toute l'histoire.
Christ est la personne,
l'être divin
pour qui l'histoire
a été orchestrée.
De sorte que nous pouvons lire
chaque page
de l'Ancien Testament
et voir de façon typologique
notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Mais,
non seulement il y a
des enjeux théologiques,
mais ce qui est le plus triste,
ce sont les enjeux pratiques
de ces convictions.
parce qu'il ne faut pas
que les Hébreux se trompent.
Dans quel état
on trouve les Hébreux
dans le livre aux Hébreux ?
Dans quel état sont-ils ?
Dans quel état
ce qu'on imagine être Paul
leur écrit-il cette lettre ?
Paul écrit cette lettre
à des Hébreux
qui sont anxieux,
qui sont fatigués
de leur marche chrétienne,
à des Hébreux
qui devant la persécution
se demandent
si c'est la peine
de continuer,
à des Hébreux
qui sont si rapidement
enveloppés par le péché,
à des Hébreux
qui n'ont pas d'audace
devant la persécution,
la crainte de l'homme,
à des Hébreux
qui sont prêts
à renoncer
et à revenir
progressivement
en arrière.
Mais voyez-vous,
l'un des objectifs
de l'apôtre
dans cet Épitre
c'est de montrer
que leur état
est une conséquence
de leur théologie.
Et il y a un grand risque,
notamment dans les...
si vous venez comme moi
de milieux
plutôt pentecôtistes,
il y a un grand risque
de déconnecter
la théologie
de la pratique
en disant
la théologie
c'est plutôt
de l'enseignement,
c'est l'intellect,
mais moi je suis plutôt...
je suis simplement
ce que Dieu me dit
de faire.
Ce n'est pas du tout
la faction dont Dieu
fonctionne avec son peuple.
Et il ne faut pas
se tromper
ce que vous croyez
a un impact
sur la façon
dont vous vivez
aujourd'hui.
Et c'est précisément
ce que l'apôtre Paul
veut mettre en exergue.
Vous manquez de joie,
vous manquez de paix,
mais ce n'est pas étonnant
en fait.
Vous êtes attaché
à une sacrificature
dont, si on peut
la réduire en deux mots,
est instable
et imparfaite.
Comment vous pouvez
penser être stable
et parfait,
satisfait devant Dieu
en suivant
un tel rapport
à Dieu.
Donc l'auteur
a non seulement
pour but
de mettre en emphase
devant vos yeux
l'état dans lequel
tu te trouves,
chrétien,
a un lien
avec ta vision de Dieu.
Mais il a aussi
pour but,
de façon plus positive,
de répondre
aux besoins
de l'âme
de l'auditeur
en exposant
Christ
dans son ministère.
Donc,
chaque fois
que nous allons
trouver une portion
plus doctrinale
dans ce passage,
ne l'éloignons
jamais de notre
vie pratique.
L'objectif
de l'apôtre,
c'est justement
d'apaiser notre âme,
de réconforter
notre âme,
de consoler notre âme.
Vous allez me dire,
mais moi,
ça n'a rien à voir
avec mon problème
aujourd'hui.
Ça n'a rien à voir
avec la saison
dans laquelle
je suis en train
de vivre,
de me parler
du sacerdose,
du prêtrice
de Christ.
Mensonge.
Mensonge
de l'ennemi.
Il n'y a rien
de plus satisfaisant
pour notre âme
en tant que chrétien
de savoir
que notre vie
est pour toujours
gardée dans les mains
de notre souverain
sacrificateur.
Voilà la consolation
de Dieu
pour son peuple.
Et donc,
quel est le but
du chapitre 7 ?
Quel est le but
de cette exposition
du sacerdoce
de Christ ?
Eh bien,
en fait,
ce but,
il a déjà été énoncé
par l'auteur
et je vous invite
à ouvrir
au chapitre 4
et au verset 16.
C'est peut-être
un des versets
les plus,
finalement,
les plus centrales
de cette épître
puisqu'il nous montre
quel est le but
de toute cette exposition.
Chapitre 4,
verset 16.
Approchons-nous
donc avec assurance
du trône
de la grâce.
Voilà l'ordre
qu'il donne aux chrétiens.
Approchez-vous donc
avec assurance
du trône de la grâce
afin d'obtenir
miséricorde
et de trouver grâce
pour être secourus
dans nos besoins.
Approchez-vous
avec assurance.
avec audace.
approchez-vous
avec confiance
du trône
de la grâce
à cause de ce que
Jésus a déjà fait.
Et certains d'entre vous
émettraient des
mais
tu ne sais pas
ce que j'ai fait
cette semaine,
Loïc.
Tu ne sais pas
quelles étaient
mes pensées
même quand j'étais
en train de chanter.
Comment m'approcher
du Dieu Tout-Puissant ?
Mais certains d'autres,
un converti,
vont dire
mais moi,
je n'ai pas
de besoin réel.
besoin de Dieu.
Pourquoi m'approcher
avec assurance ?
Tous les mets
que nous pourrons élever
dans notre cœur,
tous les mets
qui nous empêcheront
de nous avancer
avec confiance,
avec assurance,
doivent être traités
par la vision
de Jésus-Christ
en tant que souverain
sacrificateur.
C'est l'exposition
de Jésus-Christ
qui va nous convaincre
que nous pouvons
nous approcher
avec assurance
du trône
de la grâce.
Donc,
se peut-il ce matin
que vous manquiez
de paix,
que vous soyez anxieux
parce que vous n'avez
pas été renouvelés
dans le sacerdoce
de Christ ?
Se peut-il ce matin
que vous êtes si facilement
enveloppés par le péché
ou comme l'apôtre
va le dire
au chapitre 5,
que vous ayez du mal
à discerner
entre le bien
et le mal,
c'est-à-dire que vous
n'êtes même pas capable
de mener une vie
honorable à Dieu
parce que vous manquez
d'être,
de vous approfondir
dans la doctrine
de Christ
en tant que souverain
sacrificateur.
Voilà l'exercice
dans lequel nous allons
nous lancer ce matin.
Pour reprendre
un petit peu
la structure d'Hébreu,
après quoi,
j'avancerai.
Donc,
chapitre 4,
l'auteur a dit,
je vais vous parler
de la chose
la plus extraordinaire
au sujet de Christ.
Christ est souverain,
sacrificateur
et de lui dépendent
tous les autres
offices de Christ.
Sa prêtrise,
de sa prêtrise
dépend sa royauté
et dépend son office
de prêtre.
De sa prêtrise
dépend votre salut même,
votre respiration
et l'approbation
de toutes les prières
que vous êtes en train
de faire.
Je vais vous parler
de Christ en tant
que souverain sacrificateur
mais vous n'êtes pas prêts.
Je le vois
que vous êtes apathique.
que vous êtes
paresseux spirituel.
Vous auriez dû
être des maîtres,
chapitre 5.
Vous auriez dû
être des docteurs.
Ça fait combien de temps
que vous êtes dans l'église ?
Combien de temps
que vous êtes sous l'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu ?
Que savez-vous
au sujet de Christ ?
Chapitre 6.
Non seulement
vous vous privez
de certaines choses
mais vous vous exposez
au risque
de la colère de Dieu
si en entendant
des doctrines
si élevées
vous restez apathique
et vous ressortez
de cette assemblée
sans que votre vie
et votre rapport
à Dieu
ne changent quoi que ce soit.
Chapitre 6.
Même si quelqu'un
a été éclairé
mais reste dans son
endurcissement
il est possible
que Dieu
ôte même
la capacité
de repentance
pour vous.
Chapitre 6.
Deuxième partie.
L'auteur va revenir
et dire
mais pour vous
chrétien
j'ai un bon espoir.
Oui,
vous êtes peut-être
fatigué.
Oui,
vous êtes peut-être
même paresseux
et vous avez vécu
quelques années
dans une forme
d'apathie spirituelle,
de torpeur spirituelle.
Oui,
vous n'avez peut-être
pas beaucoup grandi
spirituellement
mais j'ai bon espoir
pour vous.
Et où se fond
mon espoir ?
Parce que Dieu
est juste
et il n'a pas oublié
ce que vous avez fait
pour lui.
Et parce que
vos promesses
sont maintenant
fixées dans les lieux
célestes.
Ça ne dépend pas de vous.
Vos promesses
sont fixées
dans les lieux célestes.
Elles sont une encre
pour votre âme
et elles ont été
déposées
comme votre espérance
a été déposée
derrière le voile.
Et qui l'a déposé ?
Il revient
au chapitre 4.
votre souverain sacrificateur.
Et maintenant
il va revenir au thème.
Toute cette portion,
tous ces deux chapitres
n'avaient que pour but
de revenir au thème
qu'il avait évoqué
et maintenant
il estime que
vous êtes fin prêt
à écouter
ce que je vais dire
au sujet du sacerdoce
de Christ.
Donc aujourd'hui
on va finir ce chapitre 6.
Ce sera en réalité
par les termes
de l'auteur lui-même
une sorte d'introduction
au chapitre 7.
On va survoler
quelques aspects
du sacerdoce de Christ
en tant que souverain sacrificateur
avec pour emphase
celle-ci
Jésus-Christ
est l'accomplissement
du sacerdoce
selon les Écritures.
Jésus-Christ
est le vrai sacrificateur
selon les Écritures.
Ayant été fait
souverain sacrificateur
pour toujours
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec.
on va de façon très humble
rejoindre l'activité
que les apôtres faisaient
dans le livre des Actes
où ils allaient
dans les synagogues
et quels qu'ils faisaient
ils ouvraient les Écritures
ils tournaient les pages
dans l'Ancien Testament
ils montraient
là c'est le Messie
on va rejoindre les disciples
sur cette route d'Emmaüs
que Christ a rencontré
où Jésus-Christ
leur a enseigné
dans leur âme abattue
là ce que disait Moïse
c'était à mon sujet
là ce que disaient
les prophètes
c'était à mon sujet
quelle capacité
de restauration
pour les disciples d'Emmaüs
le Seigneur est au contrôle
rien de ce qui s'est passé
à Jérusalem
il y a quelques jours
n'était en dehors
du contrôle de Dieu
il a déjà tout accompli
et il me l'a certifié
mon coeur est en train
de brûler
en entendant ces vérités
et c'est notre prière ce matin
que notre coeur
brûle à nouveau pour Christ
et que notre coeur
brûle à nouveau
en affection
pour la parole de Dieu
qui nous a été
généreusement donnée
de sorte que
parmi nous
le moins éduqué
des chrétiens
le plus simple
et le plus humble
des chrétiens
dans notre assemblée
qui n'a aucun diplôme
mais qui a compris
le panorama biblique
des écritures
ce que Christ
est venu annoncer
et accomplir
qui a été décrit
dans l'Ancien Testament
est beaucoup plus sage
que tous les experts
de l'Ancien Testament
que tous les diplômés
en langue hébraïque
que tous les réputés rabbins
dans les synagogues
qui n'ont pourtant pas compris
les éléments fondamentaux
de l'Ancienne Alliance
et ce vers quoi
elle convergeait
le plus humble d'entre nous
qui comprend la révélation
progressive de Dieu
Dieu se révèle
et Dieu révèle son fils
dans les pages
de l'Ancien Testament
de façon progressive
et bien
non seulement plus sage
mais il est plus affermi
dans la vie ici-bas
plus capable
de discerner
le bien et le mal
et plus en capacité
de s'approcher
avec assurance
auprès du trône
de la grâce
plus en capacité
de mener une vie
qui honore Dieu
le chrétien
le plus humble
d'entre nous
le plus simple
qui comprend
cette révélation progressive
est plus capable
de tenir face
à la persécution
d'être plein d'audace
d'aller jusqu'au bout
même si sa vie
en dépend
parce qu'il a compris
et il a saisi
ce que Christ
est venu faire pour lui
et ce que Christ
a déjà accompli
Christ
est le vrai
souverain sacrificateur
selon les écritures
et le premier point
c'est
que Christ
est le vrai
sacrificateur
légitime
verset 20
à nouveau
de Hébreux 6
ayant été fait
souverain
sacrificateur
ayant été fait
notez ce verbe
passif
Jésus ne s'est pas
proclamé
souverain sacrificateur
ayant été fait
et en fait
ce que l'apôtre
fait ici
en utilisant
précisément
ces mots
c'est qu'il revient
à l'argumentaire
du chapitre 5
où il a
essayé de démontrer
la légitimité
du sacerdoce
de Jésus Christ
parce qu'il pouvait
y avoir des doutes
quant à la légitimité
du sacerdoce
de Christ
avant de me dire
Loïc
que
je me mets à la place
d'un juif
avant de me dire
que
ton Christ
a la capacité
ou le sacerdoce
de ton Christ
a la capacité
de m'en consoler
prouve moi déjà
qu'il est légitime
d'être un
sacrificateur
et prouve moi
qu'il est légitime
d'être le
souverain sacrificateur
le chef
de tous les prêtres
et on peut comprendre
la raison de ces doutes
de la part
du peuple juif
et pour comprendre
vraiment la raison
de ces doutes
on doit revenir
à l'ancêtre
instamment
et cette tension
qui existe
avec des personnes
qui se sont proclamées
non pas prêtres
mais en tout cas
qui ont exercé
le rôle de prêtres
alors que ce n'était
pas leur place
et comment Dieu
dans sa gouvernance
a voulu protéger
la prêtrise
de tous les imposteurs
pensons par exemple
à Corée
vous vous souvenez
dans le désert
Corée
qui vient avec sa famille
et qui vient voir
Moïse et Aaron
qui ont été désignés
par Dieu
comme étant les médiateurs
entre le peuple
et Dieu lui-même
ils disent
Moïse
tout le peuple est saint
il n'y a pas que vous
alors pourquoi
c'est vous
qui vous nommez
médiateur
entre Dieu
et nous
nous sommes saints aussi
réponse de Dieu
faille sismique
ouverture de la terre
plus de famille
femme
enfant
corée
on se souvient
de Saül
qui avant
l'arrivée
de Samuel
impatient
devant la guerre
ne va pas se dire
prêtre
il ne va pas avoir
cette audace
par contre
il va exercer
quelque chose
qui est propre
au prêtre
et il va faire
un sacrifice
alors que Samuel
lui avait dit
de l'attendre
parce que c'était
son rôle
en tant que prêtre
de le faire
réponse de Dieu
déchu de ta royauté
rappelez-vous
Osias
un roi
qui s'aventure
et qui rentre
dans le temple
pour brûler de l'encens
réponse de Dieu
lèpre
exclue
du peuple
isolé
jusqu'à ta mort
donc c'est normal
que le peuple juif
avait une vive aversion
contre toutes les personnes
qui se disaient
moi je suis prêtre
moi je peux faire
des sacrifices
parce que Dieu
a voulu montrer
de façon très claire
que personne
même Corée
qui était de la tribu de Lévi
que personne
même quelqu'un
qui est de la tribu de Lévi
ne pouvait pas
s'auto-proclamer
prêtre
encore moins
souverain
sacrificateur
donc quelque part
c'était
compréhensible
de la part d'un juif
que lorsqu'il entend
Jésus
est votre souverain
sacrificateur
il y a quelque chose
qui tique en lui
il dit non
Jésus
il est même pas
de la famille d'Aaron
et il est même pas
de la tribu de Lévi
comment ce Jésus-Christ
pourrait-il être
le chef de tous les prêtres
et le seul représentant
devant Dieu
imposture
fraude
mais on doit se rappeler
que ce qui fonde
la légitimité
du sacerdoce d'Aaron
c'est
la déclaration
publique de Dieu
c'est la parole
de Dieu
c'est le décret
irrévocable de Dieu
le seul fondement
de la légitimité
de l'ancienne
sacrificature
repose sur quoi
sur la déclaration
divine
sur le fait
que Dieu
les ait désignés
en tant que
souverains
sacrificateurs
Lévi
n'avait aucune raison
de recevoir
cet honneur
et pour ceux
qui se souviennent
de cet incident
Siméon
et Lévi
pour venger
le viol
de leur soeur
Dina
s'en vont
et vont agir
avec violence
avec barbarie
et c'est un acte
qui est réprouvé
par leur père
lui-même
par Jacob
qui ne reconnaît pas
leur acte
et qui va même
alors qu'il bénit
à la fin de sa vie
tous ses enfants
Siméon et Lévi
ne recevrent pas
de bénédiction
à la place
ils vont recevoir
ceci
vous vous êtes
des enfants
plein de colère
plein de violence
votre sort
vous allez être
dispersé
donc ce n'est
en aucun cas
qu'un pourrait dire
oui mais Lévi
ensuite il s'est levé
lors du vaudor
c'est vrai
mais la réalité
c'est que Lévi
ne devait pas
recevoir un tel honneur
Lévi a reçu
plutôt une malédiction
aux côtés
de Siméon
et de façon
tout à fait
biblique
Siméon a reçu
la malédiction
promise
la tribu de Siméon
a connu cette
humiliation
d'être dispersé
c'était une des tribus
les plus petites
les plus faibles
et qui très rapidement
s'est fait absorber
par les autres tribus
Lévi aussi
a été dispersé
conformément
à la parole de Dieu
mais Lévi
a été dispersé
avec une disposition
gracieuse
de la part de Dieu
Lévi n'a pas eu
terre
la tribu de Lévi
elle a été dispersée
parmi les tribus
mais de façon gracieuse
afin qu'ils puissent
agir
comme des canaux
de bénédiction
entre Dieu et le peuple
partout où ils seront
en tant que prêtre
dans des villages
que Dieu
leur a mis à part
c'est la grâce
de Dieu
qui explique
pourquoi Lévi
a été choisi
ce n'est pas Lévi
ce n'est pas les mérites
de Lévi
de la même façon
pour Aaron
Aaron n'avait rien
de particulier
pour être choisi
en tant que
la tête
de tous les autres
souverains sacrificateurs
comme vous le savez
Aaron
est le chef
des prêtres
des Kohen
en hébreu
et Aaron
est le souverain
sacrificateur
et les premiers-nés
à chaque fois
devenaient
les souverains
sacrificateurs
mais ce n'est pas
grâce qu'ils ont été
choisis
souverains
sacrificateurs
la base
de leur légitimité
ce n'était pas
ni Aaron
en lui-même
et ses mérites
ni Lévi
mais c'était
la déclaration
de Dieu
dans le désert
je fais de ta famille
un sacerdoce
donc ce qui fonde
la légitimité
c'est la déclaration
publique
la désignation
explicite
non pas d'un homme
lui-même
non pas d'un autre homme
mais de Dieu seulement
en tant que souverain
sacrificateur
celui qui est
l'instituteur
du sacerdoce
celui qui est le but
même du sacerdoce
c'est lui qui a la seule
autorité pour décréter
qui peut être
souverain
sacrificateur
et donc si Jésus
est un souverain
sacrificateur
voilà le raisonnement
si Jésus
est un souverain
sacrificateur
il faut
qu'il y ait
une désignation
explicite
de la part
de Dieu
lui-même
qu'il établit
Jésus
en tant que
souverain
sacrificateur
et voilà
l'argument
de l'apôtre
ici
si j'arrive
à vous montrer
que Christ
ne s'est pas
proclamé
souverain
sacrificateur
mais qu'il a été
nommé par Dieu
lui-même
alors il n'y a
aucun débat
parce que
le même fondement
qui a montré
que Aaron
était légitime
sera le même
pour Jésus
Christ lui-même
est-ce que
cette désignation
explicite
existe
la réponse
de l'auteur
est oui
et je vous invite
à tourner la page
dans psaume
au chapitre
un psaume
tout à fait
remarquable
psaume
chapitre
de David
psaume
paroles
de l'éternel
à mon seigneur
voilà
une introduction
au psaume
tout à fait
unique
et remarquable
d'habitude
on a
sur la guillite
ou sur la lutte
avec
chant de la biche
etc
ici
on a
paroles
de l'éternel
à mon seigneur
donc la première question
qu'on doit se poser
c'est
qui est en train
de parler
dans ce psaume
et à qui est-il
en train de parler
comme vous le savez
dans les psaumes
habituellement
surtout les psaumes
de David
ce sont des prières
que David fait
de David
à l'éternel
et au travers
de ces prières
on peut voir
de façon typologique
la relation
du Messie
envers Dieu le Père
mais ici
ce n'est pas
psaume
de David
à l'éternel
ce sont les
paroles
de l'éternel
à mon seigneur
dans le texte hébreu
c'est
paroles
de Yahvé
le tétragramme
imprononçable
à Adonai
donc quel est ce psaume
si unique
dans l'histoire
ce n'est pas un psaume
à proprement parler
de David
c'est une retranscription
David est en train
d'assister
à une conversation
entre Yahvé
et Adonai
qui est Adonai
qui est mon Adonai
quelqu'un
ou les juifs
pourraient dire
aujourd'hui
bon bah là
David
il s'appelle
lui-même Adonai
mon seigneur
c'était un titre
honorifique
jamais dans les écritures
David s'est appelé Adonai
jamais David
ne s'est appelé
mon Adonai
qui suggère
quelqu'un de supérieur
à lui-même
et de façon tout à fait claire
vous savez que les psaumes
ont été écrits
par plusieurs auteurs
par Asaph
par Corée
et aussi principalement
par David
mais dans la providence de Dieu
Dieu a voulu que ce soit
David spécifiquement
qui écrive ce psaume
parce que si c'était Asaph
qui avait écrit ce psaume
qui avait dit
de l'éternel à mon seigneur
on aurait pu se dire
bon Asaph parle de David
son seigneur
c'est David
psaume de David
de Yahvé
à Adonai
qui est donc
cet Adonai
et bien Jésus
lui-même nous l'explique
qui est cet Adonai
Jésus va faire usage
de ce passage
on n'a pas besoin
d'émettre des hypothèses
de débattre
puisque Jésus vient même
nous expliquer
non seulement ce qu'il sait
de Adonai
mais ce que les autres
comprennent aussi d'Adonai
ce que les autres juifs
contemporains comprennent
d'Adonai
et dans cette discussion
je ne vais pas vous inviter
à ouvrir
vous pourrez le lire
de votre côté
mais Matthieu 22
l'évangile selon Matthieu
Jésus va faire usage
de ce passage
dans un autre but certes
mais il va nous montrer
qui est l'identité
de cet Adonai
il va dire ça aux pharisiens
selon vous pharisiens
qui est le Messie ?
et les pharisiens
de répondre
le Messie c'est facile
question facile Jésus
le Messie
c'est le fils de David
c'est la descendance
de David
c'est quelqu'un
qui viendra
après David
et Jésus de répondre
alors si c'est le cas
pourquoi David
appelle-t-il
le Messie
mon Seigneur
mon Adonai
autrement dit
ce que Jésus
était en train de dire
c'est
si le Messie
était simplement
humain
de la descendance
de Messie
comment David
pouvait appeler
ce même Messie
mon Seigneur
quelqu'un qui
préexistait à David
donc le point de Jésus
qui n'est pas notre point ici
mais le point de Jésus
c'était de dire
le Messie
sera certes
de la descendance
de David
mais il préexiste
à David lui-même
il est Dieu lui-même
il sera homme
et Dieu
mais notre point ici
c'est de montrer
la compréhension
de Jésus
que Adonai
s'agit bien
du Messie
Adonai
s'agit bien
du Christ
du loin de Dieu
de Jésus-Christ
lui-même
ce que David
est en train de voir
c'est une conversation
céleste
entre Dieu le Père
et Dieu le Fils
David
a la fenêtre
ouverte sur le ciel
et David voit
une interaction
entre Dieu le Père
qui prend à témoin
l'humanité tout entière
parole
de Yahvé
à Jésus-Christ
lisons
le suite de ce psaume
psaume 110
de David
psaume
parole de l'éternel
et là on a toutes les clés
pour comprendre
qui est en train de parler
et à qui
parole de l'éternel
à mon Seigneur
assieds-toi
à ma droite
jusqu'à ce que je fasse
de tes ennemis
ton marche-pied
l'éternel
étendra de Sion
le sceptre de ta puissance
domine au milieu
de tes ennemis
ton peuple
est plein d'ardeur
quand tu rassembles
tes armées
avec des ornements
sacrés
au sein de l'aurore
ta jeunesse
vient à toi
comme une rosée
verset 4
l'éternel
Yahvé
l'a juré
il ne s'en repentira point
tu es sacrificateur
pour toujours
à la manière
de Melchisedec
la déclaration
publique
attendue
le décret
irrévocable
attendue
devant lesquelles
les juifs
n'avaient
aucune excuse
de ne pas
comprendre
que le Messie
ne sera pas
simplement
le sauveur
et le libérateur
mais le nouveau
chef des prêtres
celui qui sera
le médiateur
entre l'humanité
et Dieu
lui-même
voici
la déclaration
publique
devant lesquelles
ils sont
triplement inexcusables
pourquoi ?
pour trois certitudes
qui sont présentées
dans ce passage
et je vais essayer
d'aller vite
premièrement
la déclaration
explicite
telle que je l'ai évoqué
Dieu l'a bien déclarée
explicitement
ce n'est pas une interprétation
vague
c'est Dieu
qui parle
au Messie
en disant
je te déclare
souverain
sacrificateur
la même légitimité
la même façon
que Aaron
était rendu légitime
et bien maintenant
Dieu l'annonce
au Messie
directement
deuxièmement
quelle est la deuxième
certitude
et bien
cette déclaration
publique
a été renseignée
où ?
dans
l'Ancien Testament
quelque part
ça n'aurait rien changé
et ça aurait tout changé
que ça soit écrit
dans le Nouveau Testament
ça n'aurait rien changé
puisque les écrits
si Dieu avait déclaré
publiquement
dans le Nouveau Testament
qu'il allait faire
du Messie
le souverain
sacrificateur
ça n'aurait rien changé
puisque le Nouveau Testament
est la parole de Dieu
et qu'elle porte
son poids d'autorité
néanmoins
l'office
de souverain
sacrificateur
est si structurante
pour la vie d'Israël
si importante
dans leur rapport
à Dieu
que Dieu
a jugé sage
d'inscrire ça
dans les écritures
anciennes
afin qu'aucun juif
ne s'avance
vers la religion chrétienne
en disant
votre document
les écrits
des apôtres
ce sont des documents
frauduleux
parce qu'ils contredisent
l'explication
explicite
des anciennes
des anciennes écritures
inspirées par Dieu
lui-même
vous dites qu'il y a
un nouvel ordre
ce n'est pas ce qu'on a vu
dans l'Ancien Testament
vous dites qu'il y a
un nouveau sacerdoce
et un souverain
sacrificateur
ce n'est pas ce qui est dit
dans les saintes écritures
mais Dieu
dans sa sagesse
a inscrit
mille ans
avant l'avènement
de Jésus Christ
le fait
qu'il allait désigner
celui qui allait venir
comme étant
le souverain
sacrificateur
et il a décrit
si vous lisez
le reste du psaume 110
avec minutie
ce qui allait
caractériser
ce Messie
un roi
un libérateur
un souverain
sacrificateur
pour que le jour
où il arrive
toute bouche soit fermée
et tous puissent reconnaître
qu'il est bien celui
qui avait été annoncé
dans les écritures
anciennes
et troisièmement
la troisième certitude
c'est que pour
manifester
avec clarté
que Jésus Christ
sera bien
le souverain
sacrificateur
Dieu l'a juré
verset 4
du psaume 110
Dieu l'a juré
il ne s'en repentira
point
donc on sait
que Dieu
n'est pas un menteur
on sait que
tout ce que dit Dieu
il l'accomplira
mais ici
dans l'histoire
et dans le temps
il a voulu sceller
cette déclaration
pour qu'il n'y ait
parce qu'il connait
l'église
il connait les juifs
il connait le coeur humain
et il sait qu'il y aura
toujours des remises
en question
mais ici
il l'instaure
il le scelle
dans cette institution
solennelle
devant les anges
dans cette discussion
céleste
tu seras
je le jure
souverain sacrificateur
et par le psalmiste David
qui est peut-être
le psalmiste
le plus fiable
des écritures
et bien
il prend le public
l'humanité
à témoin également
je vous le jure
soyez témoins
mon fils
sera
souverain sacrificateur
Christ est le
sacrificateur
légitime
le vrai
sacrificateur
légitime
ce qui a été dit
sur la montagne
pour rendre légitime
le sacerdoce
d'Aaron
a été dit
dans les cieux
au sujet de Jésus Christ
ce qui a été dit
dans le désert
sur la terre
de façon temporaire
dans le sacerdoce
d'Aaron
et ce qui a rendu
légitime
et honorable
le sacerdoce
d'Aaron
a été dit
devant les anges
devant les armées
d'anges
et devant l'humanité
toute entière
dans les cieux
élevés
Jésus Christ
le Messie
sera
souverain
sacrificateur
et donc
mes frères et sœurs
prenons garde
à ne pas nous rapporter
comme les hébreux
qui en fait
auraient dû voir
ce psaume
c'était leurs écritures
ils avaient
cette vérité
déclarée de la part
de Dieu
devant leurs yeux
ils chantaient
même ce psaume
aveuglé
et ils considéraient
cette
cette œuvre d'art
peut-être comme un tableau
poussiéreux
devant lequel on passe
souvent tous les jours
sans y prêter attention
sans méditer
et comment cela a peut-être
notre rapport aux écritures
également
de lire
sans mêler notre foi
à ce que Dieu dit
qu'il est réellement
Dieu
nous dit
et nous rappelle ce matin
Jésus Christ
il est votre souverain
sacrificateur
légitime
ne vous rapportez pas
à Dieu
comme si Jésus
n'existait pas
ne vous rapportez pas
à Dieu
dans la contemplation
simplement de ce que
vous pouvez donner
à Dieu
comme les autres religions
le proposent
cessez de vivre
dans l'anxiété
en regardant
simplement à vos faiblesses
et à vos manquements
car j'ai établi
dans le ciel
un souverain
sacrificateur
voyez
nous vivons tous
en conformité
avec nos convictions
en réalité
nous vivons tous
en parfaite harmonie
avec nos véritables convictions
de sorte à ce que
si je regarde
une telle personne vivre
je sais en quoi elle croit
je sais quelle est
sa conviction
au sujet de Dieu
je sais quelle est
sa conviction
au sujet de l'éternité
il n'y a pas de
croyant
mais non pratiquant
ça n'a jamais été
à un langage biblique
lorsqu'on observe
quelqu'un dans sa vie
qu'on voit son anxiété
qu'on voit son attachement
en chose de ce monde
qu'on voit sa coardise
qu'on voit
son manque
d'entrain
envers les promesses
à venir
et bien on voit
ses réelles convictions
envers son espérance éternelle
il est important
mes frères
que nos convictions
au sujet de
qui est Jésus Christ
et l'espérance
qu'il a déposé
soient renouvelées
par la vérité
de la parole de Dieu
pour que nous puissions
vivre ici bas
avec audace
peu importe ce qui arrive
devant les persécutions
et la lassitude
de votre coeur
Jésus Christ
est légitime
souverain
sacrificateur
la source
de notre espérance
et de paix
c'est de savoir
que notre souverain
sacrificateur
et je lève les yeux
au ciel
peu importe
ce qui m'arrive
je suis enveloppé
si facilement
par le péché
je suis fatigué
je suis là
je suis découragé
je n'avance
que très peu
dans mes vies chrétiennes
mais Dieu a déclaré
que Christ
était mon souverain
sacrificateur
légitime
et il se tient
continuellement
devant la face
de Dieu
c'est là
que mon âme
trouve enfin
la paix
dans les pertes
dans les attentes
légitimes
je sais
qu'il y a des promesses
qui reposent
derrière le voile
là où est établi
de façon légitime
mon souverain
sacrificateur
deuxièmement
Jésus Christ
est le vrai
sacerdoce
éternel
relisons
revenons
à notre texte
d'Hébreu
au chapitre 6
il a été fait
donc légitimité
souverain
sacrificateur
et quelle est
la première caractéristique
que l'apôtre
utilise ici
pour toujours
donc la première
caractéristique
qui sert
à définir
le sacerdoce
de Christ
c'est son
éternité
et ici
dans le choix
réduit de mots
de l'auteur
on doit essayer
de comprendre
quelle est la portée
de l'éternité
du sacerdoce
de Christ
ou même
je dirais
même plus loin
qu'est-ce que
Dieu veut dire
lorsqu'il dit
je t'établis
pour toujours
parce que
vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir
que dans les écritures
et ça peut poser
beaucoup de questions
à des personnes
lorsque l'on lit
l'Ancien Testament
Dieu lui-même
a institué
plusieurs institutions
et plusieurs offices
de façon éternelle
et perpétuelle
par exemple
la Pâque
Dieu a dit
dans l'Ancien Testament
j'institue la Pâque
et ceci est
une ordonnance
perpétuelle
Dieu a dit
du règne
du roi David
c'est un
c'est un règne
éternel
on sait très bien
que le règne
de David
n'a pas été éternel
Dieu a dit
et là c'est plus important
encore pour nous
du sacerdoce
d'Aaron
que c'était
une alliance
éternelle
une ordonnance
et maintenant
on lit dans le psaume 110
qu'il va établir
Jésus-Christ pour toujours
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
est-ce que c'est le même
pour toujours
que les pour toujours
qui ont été évoqués avant ?
comment comprendre
la temporalité
des ordonnances
qui ont été données
dans l'Ancien Testament ?
est-ce qu'on doit
à chaque fois
qu'on voit le mot
pour toujours
et bien
essayer de conjecturer
de façon pragmatique
est-ce que ça c'est fini ?
est-ce que c'est pas fini ?
la réalité c'est que
pour comprendre
la temporalité
de ces institutions
et de ces offices
dans l'Ancien Testament
nous devons lire cela
à la lumière
de qui ?
de Jésus-Christ
c'est Jésus-Christ
qui donne
la compréhension
de ce qui a été révélé
dans l'Ancien Testament
de sorte que
lorsqu'on lit
de telles
formulations
relatives
à une institution
nous devons les comprendre
comme étant quelque chose
qui nous parle
de Jésus-Christ
lui-même
ils ont une valeur
typologique
qui ont trouvé
son plein accomplissement
en Jésus-Christ
lui-même
et quand on voit
ces pour-toujours
dans le cadre
de l'Alliance
mosaïque notamment
et bien on doit comprendre
que ces pour-toujours
signifient pour Dieu
jusqu'à son plein
accomplissement
ou jusqu'à ce que
pour-toujours
dans le cadre
de cette Alliance
jusqu'à ce que
cette signification
trouve son plein
accomplissement
j'institue
la Pâque
pour toujours
autrement dit
j'institue
cette fête religieuse
jusqu'à son plein
accomplissement
jusque dans les cadres
de cette Alliance
jusqu'à la fin
et on pourrait se poser
la question
mais pourquoi Dieu
ne dit pas juste ça
en fait
et on le voit
dans certaines églises
qu'ils essayent
de maintenir les fêtes
de maintenir scrupuleusement
parce qu'ils sont perdus
avec ce mot pour toujours
flou
ancienne nouvelle Alliance
faites des cabanes
on va fêter des cabanes
enfin on va pas fêter
bon
faites
faites du
du sabbat
le samedi
d'autres fêtes
que vous pouvez connaître
notamment dans
les églises messianiques
donc on peut se demander
pourquoi Dieu
n'a pas utilisé
le pour-toujours
de l'Ancien Testament
en disant
bah Dieu aurait pu dire
tout simplement
aussi longtemps
que Dieu le veut
dans le cadre
de cette Alliance
pourquoi est-il utilisé
est-ce qu'il a essayé
de nous tromper
de duper
toute une génération
la réalité
c'est que
nous devons comprendre
que Dieu a fait usage
de ces mots
à bon escient
Dieu ne s'est pas trompé
lorsqu'il a parlé
de la perpétuité
de l'éternité
de ces institutions
parce que
toutes ces institutions
et tous ces offices
avaient une valeur
typologique
qui trouveraient
son plein accomplissement
dans la réalité
éternelle
de Jésus Christ
autrement dit
lorsque Dieu demande
au peuple
de fêter la Pâque
et que ceci est
une fête
une ordonnance
perpétuelle
le Nouveau Testament
nous dit
la Pâque
c'est Christ
et donc
c'est en Christ
que nous trouvons
pour l'éternité
la libération
de la colère de Dieu
il est le sang pascal
il est l'agneau
qui a été sacrifié
pour nous
pour nous protéger
éternellement
de la colère de Dieu
il est le roi David
ultime
c'est lui qui règne
à jamais sur l'église
son royaume
est éternel
et il est
pour Aaron
la réalité éternelle
de l'éternité
du sacerdoce
d'Aaron
et donc
quand le Seigneur
utilise de façon
pédagogique
pour toujours
en parlant
d'institutions
qui ont eu une fin
des institutions
temporaires
on doit comprendre
que la pédagogie de Dieu
c'était de fixer
notre espérance
dans la stabilité
de ses institutions
j'espère que ce sacerdoce
sera éternel
j'espère que j'aurai
toujours un homme
qui défendra ma cause
j'espère qu'il y aura
toujours un roi
qui règnera avec justice
et équité
j'espère que le sang
sera toujours
sur les linteaux
de mon coeur
et que la colère de Dieu
ne m'atteindra plus jamais
et le mystère
se dévoile
en Jésus Christ
je suis l'accomplissement
à perpétuité
la fonction
de tous ces offices
et de toutes ces institutions
continue de façon éternelle
en Jésus Christ
elles ont avancé l'histoire
toutes ces institutions
pour servir
le plein accomplissement
en Jésus Christ
c'est plus clair ?
mais lorsque l'on aborde
le psaume 110
qu'on a lu tout à l'heure
et lorsqu'on aborde
la déclaration explicite
de Yahvé
à Adonai
je ferai de toi
un sacrificateur
pour toujours
et bien là
comment on doit comprendre
le pour toujours ?
là on est déjà
dans la réalité
en Jésus Christ
on n'est plus dans une ombre
qui sert à pointer
vers Jésus Christ
on est directement
dans une conversation
de Dieu
à Jésus Christ
et donc le pour toujours
ici doit être cru
tel qu'il est
Jésus Christ
notre souverain
sacrificateur
pour toujours
je ne sais pas
si vous avez remarqué
dans les écritures
lorsque vous lisez
mais il y a un schéma
qui se répète
assez souvent
que les deuxièmes générations
des hommes de Dieu
sont souvent
des générations
qui font une faillite morale
!
Adam
Qu'un
Noé
Kem
Élie
et ses enfants
Samuel
faillite morale
dès la deuxième génération
pas eu besoin
d'attendre
plusieurs générations
avant que le souvenir
du juste
soit en bénédiction
pour eux
ils ont perdu
ce souvenir
ils ont agi
avec infidélité
et dans notre cas
Aaron
et ses enfants
Nadab et Abihu
ils rentrent
possiblement
enivrés
ou ils allument
un feu étranger
frappés par la colère
de Dieu
faillite morale
dès la deuxième génération
pourquoi le Seigneur
semble-t-il
dans sa providence
avoir enregistré
ces événements
dès la deuxième génération
peut-être
pour que le peuple
d'Israël
même lorsque l'institution
a été déclarée
pour toujours
pour que le peuple
d'Israël
sache qu'en réalité
il doit fixer
leur regard plus loin
que l'institution
fait d'homme
Dieu a déclaré
pour toujours
mais nous voyons
si rapidement
dans cette institution
qu'en fait
elle est corruptible
qu'elle est instable
et que nous sommes
à nouveau
dans une situation
précaire
Nadab et Abihu
auraient dû être
ceux qui représentent
le peuple
devant la face de Dieu
instabilité
des institutions
même lorsqu'ils sont face
à la notion
de perpétuité
mais mes frères et sœurs
Christ est notre
souverain sacrificateur
pour toujours
ça c'est la réalité
ça c'est le plein
accomplissement
de sorte que
alors qu'on est en train
de parler ce matin
Christ est devant
la face du Père
pour intercéder pour nous
cette semaine
vous avez été fidèles
Christ intercède pour vous
cette semaine
vous n'avez pas été fidèles
Christ intercède pour vous
cette semaine
vous avez été angoissés
accablés
perdus dans votre tristesse
et vos attentes légitimes
Christ intercède pour vous
nous ne sommes pas
dans les mains
de souverains sacrificateurs
mortels
de Aaron
de Nadab
d'Abiou
ou quel autre saint
Moïse
Paul
Marie
la mère de Dieu
nous sommes
entre les mains
d'un souverain sacrificateur
compatissant
qui est éternellement
devant la face de Dieu
pour nous
et il plaide
éternellement
notre cause
devant la face de Dieu
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
est-ce qu'il dit
Nadia
Moïse
je plaide votre cause
et je dis à Dieu
tout le bien que vous êtes
en train de faire
pour lui ?
non
il est devant la face de Dieu
et il tend ses mains percées
sa côte ensanglantée
il dit
Dieu le père
Yahvé
regarde comme Nadia est juste
regarde comme Moïse est juste
regarde ses mains
et regarde comme Stéphane est juste
à chaque instant
notre souverain sacrificateur
est devant la face de Dieu
pour nous
au-delà de nos circonstances de vie
il ne ressortira plus
de derrière le voile
il attend notre arrivée
il est en train
continuellement
de vous préparer
une place
de sorte que
comme David le psalmiste
je peux m'endormir en paix
parce que je sais que demain
je vais me réveiller
ou pas
mais je serai dans les mains
de Dieu
je connais mon coeur
je sais à quel point
je suis vacillant
je ne sais même pas
quelle transgression
je suis possible de faire
la semaine prochaine
mais mon destin
et mon sort
est entre les mains
d'un souverain sacrificateur
qui est continuellement
devant la face de Dieu
ses prières sont
éternellement acceptées
il est éternellement agréable
devant la face de Dieu
pour toujours
souverain sacrificateur
et enfin
je finirai par cette vérité
il est le vrai
sacrificateur légitime
sacrificateur éternel
et il est
le vrai ordre
sacerdotal
ayant été fait
légitimité
souverain sacrificateur
pour toujours
éternité
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec
et aujourd'hui
on ne va pas rentrer
en détail
de l'ordre de Melchisedec
parce que ça va être
le but du chapitre 7
qu'on va voir
dès la semaine prochaine
mais nous allons commencer
à faire quelques remarques
introductives
sur ce nouvel ordre
parce qu'en réalité
quel est l'objectif
de l'apôtre ici
c'est tout simplement
en train
il est tout simplement
en train de dire
il n'y a pas de continuité
à proprement parler
entre Aaron
et Jésus Christ
Jésus n'est pas
la suite d'Aaron
il est d'un autre ordre
de sacerdoce
et cet autre ordre
n'est pas en compétition
ni en concurrence
avec l'ordre
d'Aaron
l'ordre d'Aaron
le souverain sacrificateur
et sa famille de prêtres
avaient pour but
d'être au service
du plein accomplissement
en Jésus Christ
du dévoilement
de la révélation progressive
de Dieu
en Jésus Christ
donc dès lors
que Jésus Christ
arrive dans tout son éclat
de la gloire
l'ordre sacerdotique
ancien disparaît
et devient obsolète
immédiatement
il est d'un autre
ordre sacerdotal
il n'y a pas de concurrence
il est l'accomplissement
total
et donc
apprécions la parole
de Dieu maintenant
pour
nous rendre compte
de sa préciosité
à l'égard
de la façon
dont il décrit
ce nouvel ordre
qui est ce Melchisedec
je ne vois pas
trop de nouveaux
aussi
quelques-uns
je vais en voir
il y a peut-être
des nouveaux parmi nous
qui ne connaissent
même pas
qui est ce personnage
j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un
qui croyait
que c'était
Méphibochette
donc c'est un sacerdos
boiteux
dans les écritures
non
qui est ce Melchisedec
dont il est question
dans ce passage
de quoi
l'apôtre
est-il en train
de parler
qui est ce nom
étrange
et peut-être que ça fait
des dizaines d'années
que vous êtes dans l'église
et vous-même
vous avez toujours
approché ce nom
avec un peu de recul
qui est ce Melchisedec
et j'aimerais vous inviter
simplement pour conclure
à tourner nos regards
vers la beauté
la préciosité
de la parole de Dieu
à cet égard
on sait très peu de choses
de Melchisedec
dans l'Ancien Testament
on sait très peu de choses
sur les
j'ai demandé à Tchad GPT
sur les 23 000 versets
de l'Ancien Testament
savez-vous combien
font référence
à Melchisedec ?
deux
seulement deux mentions
du nom Melchisedec
dans toutes
les saintes écritures anciennes
de Malachie
de Genèse
jusqu'à Malachie
on sait très peu de choses
et la première fois
qu'il y a l'apparition
de ce nom Melchisedec
c'est dans la Genèse
dans une rencontre
qui paraît tout à fait anodine
entre Abraham
qui ne s'appelait pas encore Abraham
Abraham et ce prêtre Melchisedec
et dans ce passage
on va le lire la semaine prochaine
mais dans ce passage
qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
on a le roi de Sodome
qui est en guerre
avec d'autres rois
et lors de cette guerre
et bien la famille de Lot
sont des victimes collatérales
de cette guerre
et elles se font kidnapper
Lot, toute sa famille
sa femme
ses enfants
et tout le monde
se fait kidnapper
par les rois ennemis
du roi de Sodome
Abraham
vient au secours
du roi de Sodome
parce qu'Abraham
était alors puissant
et il emmène toute une armée
et il monte en guerre
il s'engage dans la guerre
il gagne
il récupère Lot
il ramène tous les biens
et toutes les choses
qui ont été pillées
au roi de Sodome
le roi de Sodome
vient voir Abraham
le remercier
lui dire merci
pour ton engagement
dans cette bataille
et ensuite
vient un autre roi
un autre prêtre
à la rencontre d'Abraham
il bénit Abraham
il s'appelle Melchisedec
et il disparaît
une rencontre
tout à fait anodine
dans la Genèse
et d'ailleurs
Abraham ne revient
plus jamais
sur cette rencontre
qui paraît
tout à fait dérisoire
il y a tellement
de noms
qui sont dans ce chapitre
de roi
roi de machin
je n'ai même pas retenu
que le roi Melchisedec
qui apparaît
semble tout à fait anecdotique
et dans tout le reste
de la Genèse
jamais l'auteur
ne revient sur ce nom
ni dans Exode
Lévitique
nombre
de Théronome
aucune mention
dans toute la Torah
de Melchisedec
à nouveau
Josué
Juge
Ruth
1 de Samuel
1 et 2
Chronique
Ezras
Némi
Esther
Job
aucune mention
du roi Melchisedec
jusqu'au psaume 110
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
où là
dans
l'interception
d'une discussion
entre Dieu
et Dieu lui-même
Dieu évoque à nouveau
ce prénom oublié
Melchisedec
et on peut imaginer
simplement juste
l'étonnement
de David
ou même des personnes
qui ont commencé
à chanter
l'epsaume de David
en disant
mais Melchisedec
ça nous dit quelque chose
ce nom
c'était pas un nom
qui avait été évoqué
longtemps
il y a longtemps
dans la Genèse
dans la Torah
écrite par Moïse lui-même
qui est ce Melchisedec
et nous voyons
comment cette rencontre
tout à fait anecdotique
qui nous paraît
dans la Genèse
quand elle est rappelée
par Dieu lui-même
qui parle à Dieu lui-même
Adonai
et bien tout de suite
toute son importance
est rappelée
l'importance
de ce verset
si anecdotique
dans les Écritures
est maintenant
rappelée à toute l'humanité
mais ce n'est pas encore
tout à fait clair
pour le peuple de Dieu
pour le peuple d'Israël
qui est ce Melchisedec
dont Abraham
que Abraham a rencontré
et dont Dieu
est en train de
rappeler son nom
et bien
l'apôtre maintenant
dans Hébreu
va nous expliquer
dans le chapitre 7
quelle est la signification
de cette rencontre
qu'est-ce que veut dire
cette rencontre
entre Abraham
et Melchisedec
quel est le rapport
entre cette rencontre
anecdotique
entre la déclaration
céleste
de psaume 110
et l'accomplissement
en Jésus Christ
voyez le panorama
de la révélation
progressive de Dieu
qui prend du temps
pour enseigner
avec son peuple
au sujet
du sacerdoce de Christ
un office
si élevé
c'est de la
la doctrine solide
c'est de la nourriture
solide
et voyez à quel point
des versets
un seul verset
est digne
de notre méditation éternelle
un verset
si anecdotique
dans la Genèse
va maintenant
être le sujet
de notre contemplation
de notre adoration
dans l'exposition
du ministère
de sacerdoce
de Jésus Christ
la préciosité
des écritures
Dieu ne parle
jamais en vain
quel bon rappel
lorsque nous lisons
la parole de Dieu
un verset
qui peut nous sembler
anecdotique
a été interprété
par l'apôtre lui-même
inspiré du Saint-Esprit
pour élever nos regards
sur la stature de Christ
et pour que nous puissions
trouver notre espérance
notre paix
notre confiance
de cette rencontre
entre cet homme et Abraham
quelle beauté
que les écritures
quelle profondeur
Dieu est fiable
Dieu non seulement
se révèle
tel que nous devrions
l'adorer
mais il se révèle
dans sa fiabilité
par les écritures
il est digne
de notre foi
et en Christ
tout ce mystère
de ce nom Melchisedec
se dévoile
enfin
la rencontre
prend du sens
le psaume
et on pourrait se demander
mais pourquoi
la révélation de Dieu
est aussi lente
pourquoi elle est aussi
progressive
pourquoi lorsqu'Abraham
je ne sais pas
a rencontré
Melchisedec
et bien
Melchisedec n'a pas dit
et bien écoute
je suis du nouvel ordre
de sacerdoce
et le Messie
qui arrivera prochainement
sera de mon ordre
sacerdotal
et parfois
on peut se poser
ces questions
dans les écritures
et peut-être même
que le peuple juif
se pose ces questions
pourquoi attendre
la pleine révélation
en Jésus Christ
pour comprendre
ce que Dieu avait révélé
je pense qu'on trouve
un élément de réponse
dans l'épître aux hébreux
et dans la structure
de l'épître aux hébreux
elle-même
je vous rappelle
la structure
que j'ai évoquée au début
chapitre 4
je veux vous parler
du souverain sacrificateur
mais vous n'êtes pas prêts
je veux vous parler
de cet office
si majestueux
si beau
mais j'ai peur
qu'en restant apathique
devant l'exposition
et bien vous vous exposiez
à un grand danger
j'ai peur
que votre cœur
ne soit encore plus
endurci
Dieu traite
l'humanité
tout entière
avec patience
Dieu traite
sa révélation progressive
parce qu'il connaît
le cœur
de l'humanité
et il connaît
à quel point
le cœur
de l'homme
est prompt
à s'endurcir
devant la révélation
de Dieu
même si elle est
explicite
comme on l'a vu
de psaume 110
en fait il n'y a rien
de plus explicite
que Dieu
qui parle à Dieu
lui-même
et même cette révélation
a été une source
de débat
et de refus
non seulement
Dieu gère l'histoire
avec patience
mais Dieu gère
nous gère
avec patience
certaines personnes
sont dans cette église
aujourd'hui
après des années
et des années
en ayant navigué
d'une église
à une autre
mais si Dieu veut
que vous soyez là
à l'écoute
de ce passage
c'est parce qu'il vous a
traité avec patience
il savait ce que vous
étiez capable de recevoir
il y a dix ans
il savait ce que vous
étiez capable de comprendre
il y a dix ans
Dieu nous traite
avec douceur
avec sagesse
il traite chaque âme
comme les âmes
de l'histoire
avec tendresse
avec confiance
ne désirant pas
que vous vous perdiez
de sorte que lorsque
vous entendrez
et que vous comprendrez
vous reconnaîtrez
la voix de votre bon berger
en temps voulu
dans le temps pourvu
par Dieu
lui-même
Amen